so the global chemical weapons watchdog
the OPCW is currently holding talks
today on possible measures and funding
that would allow it to crucially
apportion blame juries investigations
there to the Russian side of it of that
delegation at the OPCW those slammed the
idea and called it a political tactic
and assisted Churkin is across the story
this is happening at a session of the
OPCW where Russia is in fact expressing
very strong opposition to the idea of
the organization for the prohibition of
chemical weapons being able to assign
blame and point fingers outside of the
usual scope that has existed until
recently where they investigate the use
of chemical weapons so this is something
that Russia says is in violation of
international regulations specifically
taking away this prerogative from the
United Nations Security Council which is
essentially in charge of dealing and
ruling on issues of war and peace here's
some more detail from the Russian and
vuoi to the OPCW we believe that the
potential decision on the opcw's budget
which according to the Secretariat's
plan should increase by four million
euros is illegitimate it's a direct
outcome of the decision taken in June we
believe our colleagues are planning to
use the money for granting power to the
OPCW to identify the guilty and we
believe that decision should be blocked
all of this comes at a time when we are
seeing sort of anti Russia euphoria and
a wave of blame being assigned against
Russia this has all come up this summer
where the UK had the initiative to put
forward this idea of allowing the OPCW
to assign blame as part of its work and
we know that 82 countries out of 193
members of the OPCW had supported this
idea where 24 voted against it and 26
abstained and this Russian and voy to
the OPCW also pointed out that according
to him the scruple attack accusations
are baseless he talked about how neither
the OPCW nor port and down worry
to assign the origin of the novel Chuck
being talked about he said that he
thinks there's no doubt that Porton Down
has previously worked and continues to
work with Nava Chuck type agents he's
also denied any accusations made against
Russia just last week trying to blame it
for attempting to carry out a cyber
attack at the OPCW
you